11:54 and henry ii has become king of
england unlike most of his predecessors
his succession didn't lead to a
prolonged civil war which was a nice
change of pace henry ii was not just the
king of england he was also the duke of
normandy the count of Anjou and the Duke
of Aquitaine this meant that alongside
all of those titles he ruled all of this
territory making him the most powerful
ruler in all of Europe the large domains
which he held were both the strength and
a weakness
Henry was unsurprisingly extremely
wealthy since he was able to tax the
export of goods made in his French
holdings such as wine and salt and also
had the largest taxable population in
Europe the weakness of all this
territory was that he made enemies with
the King of France and the other French
Nobles who felt that Henry was far too
powerful to put this into perspective
these were the borders of medieval
France and these were the parts of said
kingdom which swore their allegiance to
Henry not the French King Louie the
seventh shockingly this arrangement was
not popular with louis henry attempted
to stabilize the english kingdom after
the turmoil of the civil war during his
predecessors reign he first managed to
intimidate Scotland's King Malcolm the
fourth to give back the territory
Scotland had previously seized
throughout the next decade Henry found
himself involved much more in the
squabbles of his French neighbors in
fact Henry spent the majority of his
reign in his French holdings which was
centered at chignon here this is
important in highlighting that the
Plantagenet should not be seen as
English Kings with French holdings but
as French Nobles who were also the kings
of England Henry managed to expand his
territory to this with the most notable
game being the Duchy of Britain in 1166
Henry also managed to force the
submission of Tolu briefly in the
following decade but it didn't last
Henry's relationship with the rest of
France did not improving in 1167 he
banned English monks from learning at
the University of Paris which led to the
rapid growth of Oxford is a major site
of learning so Henry had three major
issues moving forward the first was the
relationship between the crown and the
church the second was the conquest of
Ireland and the third was by far his
greatest problem the succession Henry's
issues with the church revolved mostly
around one man Thomas Becket whom Henry
was close friends with and had made the
Archbishop of Canterbury in 1162 Henry
had hoped that by appointing a friend
his issues with the church will be
glossed over
unfortunately for Henry Thomas was a
principled man and almost immediately
began berating the King for his
violations of church rights one of the
main issues were surrounding a classical
course which will cost the church used
to judge the clergy since according to
church doctrine secular courts were not
fit to judge holy men this annoyed Henry
since
there were criminals in his kingdom who
didn't have to answer to him and to
secular courts would often punish people
by seizing property thus giving the King
more revenue which he liked Beckett
defied the Kings wish to try men of the
church in 1164 Henry put Becket on trial
for trumped-up charges which were
essentially you don't like the king so
you have to go back it was found guilty
and fled to the continent leaving the
King to do whatever he wanted in 1169
Henry turned his attention to the
conquest of Ireland Henry had been
considering this since 1155 when you
received permission to do so from Pope
Hadrian the fourth the only English Pope
ever the authenticity of this permission
is disputed and some believe Henry made
it up as a convenient excuse to conquer
irrespective of the authenticity of this
permission Henry got to conquering the
first people to go to Ireland were
mercenaries who were helping a deposed
Irish King though in 1170 some of
Henry's nobles went over most notably
Richard de Clare and managed to swiftly
conquer this area Henry at this point
was also dealing with his third problem
what to do about the succession in 1169
his eldest son also called Henry was
coronated as king alongside his father
Henry the young king as he's known did
not hold any real power it simply made
it clear that he was the undisputed heir
Thomas Becket still in exile was unhappy
that the Archbishop of Canterbury's
right the crown Kings had been
sidestepped it was however negotiated by
the Pope that Becket could return which
he did and he quickly went back to
annoying the king by 1170 Henry was
frankly fed up with Becket in in a rage
he said something along the lines of
will nobody rid me of this meddlesome
priest this was understood by some
Knights as a request to murder him these
Knights travelled to England on December
the 29th 1170 Becket was stabbed to
death inside Canterbury Cathedral this
murder shocked the Christian world and
pretty much ruined Henry's reputation
since murdering Archbishop's is mostly
frowned upon Becket was swiftly declared
a saint but from a practical perspective
this did make Henry's job a lot easier
so allegedly Henry was concerned that
Richard Eclair was about to declare
himself the king of an independent Irish
Kingdom and so in 1171 he landed there
with the large force to keep things in
check by the time Henry left Ireland the
next year his whole ovary looked like
this with those that ruled the remainder
having pledged loyalty to him this
marked the beginning of sustained
English and later British intervention
in Ireland which still continues to this
day
this meant that Henry's domain at its
height looked like this with these areas
from Scotland to talut pledging their
loyalty to him these lands are often
collectively referred to as the Angevin
Empire side note on the name the word
Angelyn comes from Anjou the
Sheila plantagenet sirisha Nellie held
the word Empire is more difficult since
it is a modern term and was not used at
the time to describe the Angevin lands
henry ii despite being the wealthiest
and most powerful monarch in europe at
the time did not and would not have
referred to himself his emperor the
reasons for this are clad in complex
theology but there could only be one
real emperor and that was the Holy Roman
Emperor so the conquest of Ireland fed
into the continuing problem surrounding
the succession the problem with being a
king is that your sons often can't wait
for you to die so they can take your
stuff and Henry sons were no different
Henry's domain simply wouldn't pass from
father to old his son but was supposed
to be portioned out between them to stop
him from fighting Henry the young king
was to get Anjou Normandy in England
Henry second son Richard was to get
Aquitaine Geoffrey was to get Brittany
and Henry's youngest John was to get
island unsurprisingly literally none of
his sons were happy about this except
John who was only eight Henry's Restless
sons found help from the king of France
who was more than happy to do anything
that would undermine Angevin power in
1173 Henry sons would enter open
rebellion against him Henry the young
king was sick of not having any real
power and wanted more money Richard and
Geoffrey wanted more land than Henry had
promised and John was still busy being
eight the three sons teamed up with the
King of France the King of Scotland the
Count of Flanders and also Henry's wife
Queen Eleanor in invading the Angevin
territories they all launched invasions
at roughly the same time and all of them
were defeated rebellions and civil war
continued into the next year but number
even remotely successful and Henry sons
all surrendered a series of deaths in
the 1180s change Henry's situation
dramatically in 1180 King Louie the
seventh for France died and was
succeeded by Philip Augustus who was
obsessed with retaking French lands in
1183 Henry the young king died and in
1186 the third son Geoffrey died as well
leaving only Richard and John as heirs
Richard was concerned that his previous
rebellions would give his father an
excuse to pick John instead and so did
the only thing he could think of rebel
again he did this in 1189 with the help
of Phillipe Augustus who together
invaded and quickly push back the armies
of the now dying henry ii henry
surrendered to both Richard and Philip
and died shortly afterwards in Anjou
after his father's death Richard took up
his French titles and went to England
and on the 3rd of September he was
crowned King Richard the first so Rich's
reign is famous for one thing above all
his crusade which is where he earned his
famous epithet Richard the Lionheart so
richard had already agreed to go on a
crusade in 1187 which was called in
response to the fall of Jerusalem
King Philip Augustus of France had also
agreed to go on this crusade nism
and to know that those who were
crusading were under special protection
by the Pope if a person took the cross
the term used for those who went on a
crusade their lands were supposed to be
left alone and it was illegal in theory
to capture or harm those on their way to
or from the Holy Lands as will become
evident this did not always happen
Richard raised taxes ransomed the King
of Scotland and sold titles and
positions in government called offices
to raise revenue for his Crusader army
in 1190 he departed for the Holy Land
stopping off at Sicily on the way where
he found his sister Joan imprisoned
there was some fighting and pillaging
but after being paid off Richard freed
his sister and moved on before his fleet
to get to the Holy Land it was dispersed
by a storm and Richard ended up at
Cyprus there was some conflict with its
ruler a Byzantine Prince could Isaac
Komnenos and Richard peacefully
negotiated a settlement just kidding
instead he conquered the island and
through Isaac into prison
later that year Richard arrived in akka
here and soon after sold Cyprus to the
Knights Templar because money whilst
they were there richard and philip
augustus fell out and philippe returned
to france
richard was unable to retake to rusul
him but he once a major victories
against his famous rival Saladin in the
end richard signed a treaty with Saladin
which secured the remaining Crusader
states of Antioch on Tripoli and
importantly granted safe passage to the
Christians in the Holy Land
so back in Rich's domains there had been
several revolts the most notable being
by his brother John nothing came of
these rebellions due mostly to the good
leadership of the memberid had entrusted
with his kingdom namely william the long
champ and hugh de PUE say these men were
appointed as joint just akia's which
essentially meant that the active with
the Kings Authority whilst he was away
this does not mean that there were no
issues in England during Richard's time
crusading in 1190 there was a massacre
of Jews throughout the country notably
at York and it was later declared that
Jews could not make any transactions
without it being documented by the crown
Richard began his journey back from the
Holy Land in 1192 on the way he was
captured near Vienna and was imprisoned
by the Duke of Austria Leopold v who was
swiftly excommunicated that is expelled
from the Christian faith by the Pope for
this richard was handed over to the Holy
Roman Emperor was ransomed in early 1194
riches time in prison proved costly
first in terms of money since his ransom
was cripplingly expensive being the
equivalent of over two years worth of
taxes raised in England the other way it
was costly was instability for his
kingdom during his imprisonment John
kept rebelling and philippe augustus of
france made military incursions but he
made little gains richard returned to
england forgave his brother for his
rebellion some made him his heir since
richard had no sons
richard would then spend the next five
years of his reign retaking
the lost territories Richard also took
the motto do em on thoir which means God
and my right Richard also appointed a
man called Hubert Walter as Archbishop
of Canterbury who ruled England
effectively in Richards name water was
able to raise the massive taxes needed
for Richards ransom as well as those
needed for his war against Philippe
water also managed to suppress rebellion
to negotiate with the neighbouring Kings
to prevent invasions in 1199 whilst he
was suppressing a revolt Richard was
injured by a Lu's crossbow bolt and soon
after died of his wounds thus leaving
the way of him for John one of the most
notorious Kings in English history
ultimately Richards legacy is a complex
one he's often seen as a paragon of
Christian chivalry but it's important to
remember that whilst he was the
embodiment of a holy Crusader he was
also a rebel and one whose kingdom was
in many respects little more than a
revenue pot for his boring I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching there are some book
recommendations in the description if
he'd like to know more
you